have you ever done bun stuff oh yeah i
love a bit of anal
what do you think i got bowel trouble a
little warning to anybody out there
i thought you wanted some details
[Music]
what's your relationship like
like best friends really yeah we are
like best friends i've just brought him
up to be very open and honest and we
discuss everything any problems
of any subject relationships sex oh yeah
oh yeah
that's the main thing
i'm deprived i've got to get it all from
liam
[Laughter]
great
[Laughter]
if you switch genders for a day what's
the first thing you do have a toss
i want to know what it's like
it seems so easy for a man do you know
what like i don't know what i would
expect myself to say that but if you
just go go i'll have a toss yeah but i
want to see what it's like
it seems so much better for men
don't be done in it
jesus christ see you're lucky you just
lay there and just you know felt when i
was lucky am i your favorite child
oh no that's terrible
come on go on then go
that was pretty long
[ __ ] got it on your arms
it's good isn't it i feel a bit cruel
but oh you wait
stop stop it i didn't do anything
have you ever been attacked attracted to
one of my friends
i've never asked this question oh my god
i might have to press the buzzer almost
one day
no please answer it
yeah you have been okay right most of
them most of them
what do you mean most of them only got a
few that's enough
do i even ask who
would you want to know i don't even know
well you missed a chat one of course oh
tom yeah yeah with his long hair i'd
like to give that a pull
but
have you ever done bun stuff oh yeah i
love better of vanilla
what do you think i got bowel trouble a
little warning to anybody out there
what's wrong with that i thought you
wanted some details no all right i don't
want no details
none at all thank you i really don't
want to know this do you want me to
shock you instead what's your favorite
sex position oh i like doggy style
oh sorry wrong
it's better straight out of the gate
didn't you get any chance
you ain't got a beat around the bush
with these things well clearly not in
dogs and if you're fortunate the
wheelbarrow is good
[Applause]
if you've got somebody who's quite fit
and energetic will bow is good right i
took one all across the floor
[Applause]
this is so bad this is whistler four
would you feel uncomfortable letting me
scroll through your camera roll
well
a bit approach definitely
you know i did a rock symbol whilst
doing that
you can't scroll through me i would
rather not no i wouldn't were you not
the hidden ones don't do that
how many people did you date before dad
dad was my first okay yep
since then bit different but he was the
first
well me and liam's dad split up
in 1999 i think it was yeah
and
i moved out with my two and
and i kind of went on a bit of a roller
coaster from there i was seeing seven
seven guys it you know like one at night
i'll come around williams and lorna's in
bed
you know that type of thing a bit of fun
it had to be dundee
you know i was restricted
and um
yeah and then obviously you know the
other stories with the
there's two no the one with the there
were several people in our room everyone
there's two situations here
hell there were seven separate men the
other time and then there's seven people
one room yeah
excuse me yeah i got a bit of swinging
gotta be done
it's gotta be done on there you can't go
through life not having done that
i i had to have a dabble in all of it a
dabble in order yeah i had a dabble i
had a hell of
i don't even answer this one oh i'm sure
there's been so many
how many people have you slept with 98
i'm sorry
98.
how in the hell's them can you answer
that straight like that well because
i've got the last one stuck in my head
i just know because i counted them up at
all at one time wrote them all down and
i thought flip me what a hussy
that's not bad for 54.
are you proud of me i'm very proud very
proud of what you are who you've become
how you've turned out how you care about
other people how you help other people
you're always there for your friends if
they message
everything i'm extremely proud of you
you're my best me aren't you so
all right thank you
thank god the chair's going to fall over
get bob you have to stand up
thank you mom
rightly
am i allowed to take these off now i
don't know
all right okay
all right okay
what's your favorite sex position
i'm not i'm not answering that i am not
answering that
why not i don't want to explain those to
you yeah and i didn't want to know you
can't be just man on top women need more
shut up mother look at my finger